Oh satellite launch no I maybe it's just
an amazing process to be I think it's
everybody at least my childhood dream to
actually go to to be a granted full
access get inside actually touch this
thing that's going to go into space and
work on it is absolutely amazing
but there are some quirks associated
with that because this is this is an
extremely controlled environment there's
a few places like this anyone the earth
and the materials they're working with
solid rocket fuel and liquid oxygen
liquid hydrogen these are extremely
volatile fuels so in order to actually
gain access to the sort of inner sanctum
sanctorum the place where we build the
rocket we had to go through some hoops
and one of the things that really came
through in the answer they were willing
to grant me access but they wouldn't
necessarily grants the cameraman or
sound access nobody else can come into
some of the really sensitive places with
me so because of my history and some
personal training and some of the
training that I went through there they
were comfortable with me going in but
nobody else so I kind of became a
one-man and bad man for someone out of
some of the operations bringing in the
solid rocket boosters this is basically
a giant stick of dynamite right there's
no it's a solid fuel if it gets igniter
if anything goes wrong there's no way to
turn it off it's gonna burn til it's
gone
surely kill all let's hit the building
could probably make a pretty big crater
take out a big section of the whole
space facility there so I would go into
these some of these places you know
dressed from head to toe chemical
resistant clothing and with a
specialized gas mask there's all sorts
of things that are potential dangers
fireproof clothing I've got everything
ready to go and I would go in with my
own camera wired for sound and I would
try to document the process as I'm
working document myself but holding the
camera out document the other guys that
I'm working with and I mean as a result
of the flood footage you're gonna see in
this is pretty pretty jerky and it's got
odd angles and it's it has a real sort
of in the moment danger feel and that's
like that's not staged at all it's
completely real so you'll see some odd
angles and you'll hear some some
scratchy audio but that's because I'm
trying to produce a huge amount of this
show all by myself from inside these
controllers
I just hope people you know understand
that out that's the way I sit and go
ahead and do it that way because there's
no other way to get access the
alternative is to go home right nobody
wants to go home we want to go inside so
for certain areas of this show on the
space station it's pretty much just the
audience and me the old people are
getting